[Music]
so now we're going to move over
to the long read sequencers we're going
to start with oxford nanopore sequencing
and with this sequencing technology it
uses these nanopores
which are extremely small pores with
really small gaps in them so in this
case 1.8 nanometers
that are embedded in lipid membranes
these lipid membranes
act as a barrier that prevent currents
from going back and forth so currents
have to pass through the pore and the
way the nanopore sequencer works is
single-stranded dna or even rna in this
case now
are threaded through the pore and
depending on which bases
are in the pore to give a moment that
changes the current that's read out
and detectors can measure this change in
current
and over here is just a depiction of
what this looks like so for instance you
might have a similar
one level of current for your t's
different ones for gs
something else for c's and then another
level current for a's
and you can just measure these current
traces over time
and build a sequence in reality the
traces don't look this clean
because in the poor they're actually up
to six bases at a time present
and with six bases times four different
possible bases for your acs g's and t's
uh this generates up to four thousand
different possible states
and so it's really a technical toward a
force to get this to work but today
um you can get this to work you can buy
these systems and they do have high
error rates anywhere from 10 to 15
percent
and these errors tend to be biased but
you can get really really long reads the
current record
is a two megabase or 2 million base read
from a single piece of dna
and again as i mentioned you can now
directly sequence rna so you don't have
to convert that to dna
and there are even possibilities of
sequencing proteins in the future which
will be very exciting
the other benefit of the oxford nanopore
system is that it's extremely portable
you can see this scientist is actually
doing some sequencing out in the field
this looks like a jungle somewhere in
the world you can see the foliage in the
back so there's a laptop run in the
sequencer
and the sequencer is actually the small
device that
the scientist is pipetting into it's
really the survise
of a small remote control and it's
powered by
the computer that's attached to so it
means you can really take sequencing
anywhere in the world
these systems have even been taken up to
the international space station
for sequencing in space
so the last technology i'm going to talk
to you about today is specific
biosequencing and this is another
sequencing by synthesis method and it
uses
building blocks similar to traditional
sanger sequencing and luminous
sequencing but they're slightly
different
so down here i'm showing you an a base
from the pacific biosequencer
and you'll notice first there's no block
on the thread hydroxylane this means
that once this gets incorporated
another base can get incorporated right
away
and then the fluorescent group is
actually attached to the phosphates
and these phosphates actually are
removed
once a base is incorporated this means
that this fluorescent group
once it gets incorporated into a dna
strand will float away from the dna
strand
so this means that we don't have to do
separate chemistry to enable the
reaction to proceed this happens in
in real time and
on the instrument there's a really
really
tiny array of wells into in a plate
and these wells are only about 100
nanometers in height
at the bottom of each of these wells is
a dna polymerase
and what happens is a template molecule
is bound to polymerase and then it
starts incorporating those modified
bases
and there's a camera at the bottom
that's taking the video that's
monitoring this reaction in real time
so remember we have four different bases
that have four different colors
and these bases are flowing in and out
of this well
really really quickly and so you get a
signal
that's uh just kind of very noisy you
don't really see anything happening but
when the proper base
is bound to the plum race and matches
the template
it actually dwells there for a certain
amount of time it's really a split
second
but that split second gets recorded by
the video and you see this bump up
and the fluorescent signal in this case
blue which is the g base
and so once incorporation occurs the
phosphates leave and the
fluorescent group that hatched the
phosphates also leaves and resulting in
the signal dropping back down
to this uh this background level and
this will continue
until the next base that's correct binds
and you'll see another spike and so by
looking at these spikes and signals
across
anywhere from one to eight million wells
at a time we can build up dna sequences
[Music]
and pack biosequencing generates long
reads anywhere from one to two hundred
kilobases in length so this is
shorter than the nanopore sequencing but
it's still much longer than illumina
sequencing
it also has a high air rate similar to
oxford nanopore sequencing
but its errors are random this is
actually a good thing because the errors
are random
if you sample the same dna molecule
several times you could generate a very
accurate consensus sequence
and on the top is a model of what a
pac-bio library looks like there's a dna
sequence
and the adapters in green actually cause
the dna become this dumbbell shape so
it's one
circular structure and when a polymerase
binds and starts to sequence and
actually go around and around this
molecule many many times
generating a series of of reeds that are
all attached together they came from the
same identical template
so for instance if we have a mutation
present in a sample
and one to detect this this mutation
should be present
in all the copies and so if we match up
all of the
different reads together they came from
the same molecule we can see that the
true mutation is actually detected we
see that in every
single read and then other random errors
that show up
don't match up with each other and this
allows us to generate a very accurate
consensus that has an accuracy of
anywhere from one to a thousand to one
in ten thousand actually so even
exceeding
raw illumina sequencing accuracy
so why do long reads because there are
certain downsides they're harder to
repair
in general they cost more but there are
certain benefits
and one example is if you want to
assemble a new genome that hasn't been
sequenced
before and so this is kind of like
solving a puzzle that's been either
split into
10 000 pieces or into four pieces uh
limited sequencing and this is analogous
to the ten thousand pieces because you
have many many short reads that you have
to stitch together and this can be very
very difficult
however you have very long reads and not
that many of them it's really easy to
align them
to rebuild this new genome that you want
to assemble
it's also useful if you want to identify
structural variations so for instance in
a lot of
human cancer samples there aren't just
single base changes in mutations there
are some that are structural variations
where there are
huge chunks of dna that have been moved
to different areas of the genome here or
there
or flipped around and these can be very
difficult to detect
by short read illumina sequencing but if
you have really long read sequencing
you can span these changes and then
really easily identify the structural
variations
lastly you might want to identify where
mutations come from for instance
in humans we get one set of our
chromosomes from mom
one set from dad and there can be
mutations on
either one synonymous mutations might be
on the same set of chromosomes
some might be on either one and to be
able to do this with the limit of
sequencing again is very difficult
because the short reads make it hard to
determine which chromosome they came
from
but with long read sequencing it's much
easier to do so